is cheese actually healthy hey everyone
i'm abby sharpe welcome to abby's
kitchen
[Music]
video is sponsored by ritual and we'll
be taking a look at actress and
lifestyle youtuber lauren geraldo but
first let me tell you my sponsor ritual
so first of all i'm not pregnant anymore
and i'm finally finished breastfeeding
but i officially got my period back
after 20 years of not having a natural
period and that means anything could
happen now i also know a lot of you are
actively trying to conceive or are
already pregnant or are recently
postpartum and looking to maintain your
health during this new phase of life i
know the supplement world is really
overwhelming but i like rituals prenatal
because it's third party tested anna has
12 high quality nutrients like
methylated 4th generation folate b12 d3
and omega 3. ritual is all about
focusing their multivitamins on the
nutrients you actually need and they're
really transparent about where they
source their nutrients from and why as
well as their environmental impact so
for example they use 100 recycled
materials in their packaging and their
mailers are made from recycled newsprint
and plant fibers their multi is also
vegan gluten free allergen free with no
colorants added sugar additives or
unlisted ingredients and these ones have
a delayed release capsule design they
also have a regular multivitamin for men
and women a 50-plus option a postnatal
option and one specifically for teens
but it's super convenient because they
just deliver it right to your door as
part of a subscription so even when
you're having super mom brain you won't
run out so if your new year's resolution
is to conceive or you just want to fill
in some of those potential nutritional
gaps with a multi you can use my promo
code and check out the link in the
description to get 10 off of your first
three months of ritual okay back to the
video and you can pause the screen or
look at my description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating as
always please feel free to skip this
video if it's not supportive to your
journey and of course do not forget to
subscribe to this channel and ring that
little bell so that you never miss out
on an episode alright let's get into it
this is not gonna be three pieces of
crackers and like one cheese and then
like two grains of rice and then i'm so
full um i think i eat a lot and i love
eating okay so i love this little
preface right here it's as if she's
watched a few problematic what i knew
days herself or maybe my reviews have
said what in a days and she's
acknowledging that that's not her vibe i
am looking forward to this okay so this
is pre-breakfast
cheese crackers apples
and grapes it's like the pre-game okay
so as a pre-game two breakfast which
let's be real is amazing lauren has a
cheese box from starbucks on her way to
the grocery store and i already love
that she's keeping it real and
acknowledging the reality that sometimes
your fridge just is not fully stocked
with perfect ripe avocados and sometimes
breakfast is not going to be an
instagramable smoothie bowl but as she
mentions this little box is a great
little hunger crushing combo you're
getting protein and fat from the cheese
plus carbs and fiber from the fruit and
crackers starbucks has saved me many
times primal kitchen who i am personally
obsessed with because you can keep
eating great tasting amazing food
without having to compromise a bunch of
random ingredients all their stuff is
made without gluten dairy sugar soy and
canola oil long story short you don't
have to settle for bad ingredients if
you want your food to taste good and
exciting okay first off i love primal
kitchens products so no shade to them
and i get that this is an ad read and
some of these keywords were probably in
primal kitchen's messaging deck but i
still don't think we need to call out
gluten dairy sugar soy and canola oil as
being random ingredients i don't think
there's anything random or even bad
about any of these things sure it's fine
to call them out for folks with dairy or
gluten intolerances for example but i
still don't think that makes them bad
makes them just not right for that
person we can shift the language here a
major key in the avocado toast is
getting sliced sourdough i have tried
all different kinds of breads and
personally i think sourdough tastes the
best and i heard something don't quote
me on this because it's probably not
factual but apparently sourdough is the
easiest one to digest the girl is 100
right i
totally agree that sourdough hits
different both from a flavor and
nutritional perspective thanks to the
fermentation process so fermentation
helps reduce the anti-nutrient phytate
content in sourdough by 24 to 50
which therefore improves nutrient
absorption so even though the nutrition
profile of sourdough bread is similar to
that of conventional breads on paper the
nutrients may be more optimally absorbed
as for digestion research suggests that
the fermentation process not only
produces prebiotic and probiotic
properties but it also partially breaks
down gluten making it easier to tolerate
for folks with gluten or fodmap
sensitivity now it is not gluten free so
it's not appropriate for folks with
celiac or diagnose gluten intolerance
but might be tolerated better for some
in small amounts usually i'll use half
of some avocado or olive oil fresh lime
and seasoning then i put on a layer of
pesto avocado everything but the bagel
seasoning and my personal favorite part
the sprinkle of parmesan cheese okay i
get why she's famous for the toast i
love that we're getting some healthy
fats from the avocado and pesto protein
and fat from the eggs and cheese and
some carbs from the sourdough bread lazy
and quick does not have to mean
flavorless and boring now you know
because as much as i want to be healthy
i love me some cheese also like cheese
isn't unhealthy is it like is cheese
unhealthy i don't think it is well she
did not exactly ask me for
my professional opinion but i think
she's going to like it anyway no girl
cheese is not inherently unhealthy in
fact cheese is a source of calcium
protein and fat as well as other
vitamins and minerals like vitamins a
b12 phosphorus and zinc the only
circumstance in which you could argue
that it's unhealthy is if you have a
lactose intolerance or a casein protein
allergy and in the case of lactose
intolerance a lot of folks can still
enjoy smaller quantities of lower
lactose cheeses like her beloved
parmesan or lean on lactose enzyme
supplements to aid in digestion but
regardless cheese has likely gotten a
bad reputation because of its caloric
density and fat content however if you
were to compare a handful of cheese
cubes to a handful of almonds which is
generally considered a healthy food
cheese is actually lower in calories and
fat now what about the fact that it's a
saturated fat well i got a whole
video on saturated fats right here
because it is it is dense it's so dense
every single image has so many things
going on but in short the research on
saturated fat is highly controversial
and inconclusive one review on cheese
consumption specifically actually found
no relationship or a very weak inverse
relationship between dairy products and
heart disease so consuming cheese isn't
an immediate risk but we do know that
replacing that cheese or saturated fat
with more unsaturated fats in the diet
seems to confer some additional benefits
so what does this mean in real life
is this real life well exactly what
lauren did she had avocado toast with
pesto which is a nut-based spread packed
with unsaturated fats like the avocado
as well and then topped that with a
little saturated fat packed cheese a
plus ultimately i say let's focus on
what we can add rather than take away so
if cheese is selling that you enjoy
enjoy it with other healthy fats in the
rotation and we're like very into our
farm fresh drinks because there's not
process at all farm fresh eggs are
supposed to be like amazing for you the
world of eggs is overwhelming as
it is so hard to know what's best from
an ethical and nutritional perspective
amidst the cage-free free-range organic
pasture-fed claims plastered across
every carton now for the most part these
terms have actual criteria that they
need to meet which is often a lot more
lenient than you might think but farm
fresh that's not a regulated term this
literally means nothing at all it's
basically just marketing because
ultimately all eggs come from some kind
of farm but assuming these eggs are
organic and pasture fed the consensus is
that organic eggs are slightly higher in
protein compared to conventional eggs
and there is some research suggesting
that pastured eggs are higher in vitamin
a e and omega-3s so if you can get that
two-for-one combo in an egg carton then
technically yes i guess you could say
they do have a nutritional edge and i
also always do love to support a good
local farmer i used to never be an
energy drink type of person like they
would make me feel jittery but now i am
fully into it like i fully love i love
it so while a celsius energy drink is
low in sugar it typically has about 200
milligrams of caffeine which is
equivalent to two cups of coffee so yeah
if you're sensitive to caffeine but you
want like a little boost of energy
pre-workout a half isn't a bad place to
start i know i cannot even handle any
caffeine afternoon but that's just me
[Music]
can we all find ourselves a partner who
feeds us mangoes like this no but really
for a post-workout snack mangoes are a
great fast-acting carb which will help
to replenish energy stores post-workout
and she did have about 15 grams of
protein pre-workout which is likely
within the four-hour anabolic window for
muscle protein synthesis and we've got
like another meal on the way so yeah
this little post-workout quickie snack
works for me okay i don't understand
people that purposely choose chicken
breasts unless you're like bodybuilding
counting every single calorie or
something like that if i buy chicken and
i open it and there's a ton of that i'm
like jackpot i do appreciate that for
once someone isn't scared of fat and i
agree a good chicken thigh is always
going to be superior to the breast in
the flavor department flavor town and
even for calorie counters i really don't
think this is a huge deal like a four
ounce portion of chicken thighs has only
50 calories more than a four ounce
serving of chicken breast so i think
that that's something most people could
easily work into their caloric budget
for the day i have an iron deficiency
okay so instead of taking iron pills
i'll like randomly eat salt from various
locations it's like an iron deficiency
thing it's like a quirk i don't know why
we do it so lauren is likely
experiencing something known as pica
which is an abnormal craving for a
non-food item which is often related to
nutrient deficiencies like iron however
pica cravings are not exclusive to salt
and can extend to really random textures
and taste like clay dirt or soap
[Applause]
and while craving a bit of extra salt is
benign compared to the other cases as
her partner said eating the salt doesn't
actually fix the issue so we would of
course want to prioritize treating the
underlying iron deficiency and that
means focusing on iron rich foods like
animal protein beans legumes nuts tofu
leafy greens fortified cereals and dark
chocolate and then pairing that with a
source of vitamin c so that could look
like a tofu stir-fry with bell peppers
like a lentil soup or bean chili with a
squeeze of lime on top or some dark
chocolate squares with some fruit as a
snack as for supplements chelated iron
or iron bisglicinate is absorbed by the
body like the gold standard ferrous iron
but it is easier on sensitive tummies so
that might be worth trying or exploring
if iron from food just isn't enough
[Music]
everything about this still frame is
amazing we've got protein from the
chicken which is great for iron and
post-workout muscle recovery fiber-rich
carbs in the potatoes and the
microwavable rice healthy fats and fiber
in the avocado and some more fat in the
cooking oil that she used this is mwah
perfect post-workout meal all i might
suggest is adding some kind of veggie or
fruit in here for a little vitamin c
plus the antioxidants and we know that
that vitamin c also helps with the
absorption of iron also i am so happy to
see the calorie counting disclaimer here
because yeah i did kind of feel that was
kind of off-brand for her tonight is a
bit of a
special occasion so i decided to treat
myself with a bowl of wine apparently um
i know this is what i eat in a day but
i'm not hungry at the moment i don't
even think i want dinner
i think the cheese box was loki my um
breakfast today i think it's great that
lauren is honoring her hunger here and
not forcing herself to eat dinner when
she's not hungry or just for the sake of
filming a what in a day and second given
that she technically did have kind of a
breakfast with the starbucks cheese box
it makes sense that she wouldn't feel
like a fourth meal on top of that so i
don't read this as she's intentionally
restricting meals or overeating for the
sake of her video she's just listening
to her body honoring that she doesn't
feel hungry right now and keeping that
door open if and when her hunger does
creep in so with that said what are my
overall thoughts on lauren's diet so
based on our rough calculations on this
particular day lauren consumed
approximately 2 000 calories which
likely falls within her needs ultimately
these are just rough guidelines and it
does look like lauren is pretty in tune
with what her body needs if she craved
more calories after her workout or that
fourth meal i do feel confident that she
would have just listened and ate rather
than suppressed or restricted her video
actually felt quite authentic and real
and i don't see that that often here on
youtube so i didn't see her put a lot of
pressure on herself to create these like
perfect instagramable meals she shared
her little shortcuts for getting simple
and satisfying meals on the table fast
and i love that and even when she did
provide some nutrition commentary she
did so from a place of curiosity and it
didn't feel prescriptive or like it was
coming from a weight loss lens honestly
i think lauren is super cute fun and
probably someone i will continue to
watch so on that note that is all that i
have for you guys today thank you again
to ritual for sponsoring this video if
you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below on
who you'd like to see me for you next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]